如果说我因为有一个人，
他选择主动的离开我的世界，
我的世界就崩塌了，
那只能证明什么吗？
只能证明我的世界从来不曾真正的建立过。
我今年马上32岁，
收入睡前应该24~28左右吧，
工作也比较稳定。
我的那个家庭情况，
我从小初中的时候，
我妈妈去世了之后我爸再婚，
也基本上没有再管过我，
都是跟着爷爷奶奶或者是姥姥姥爷爷那边管我。
上一段经历是当时18岁的时候，
我们高中同学，
之后上大学在一个地方，
就在一块儿了，
大学毕业之后就结婚了，
一直就没想过就会出什么问题嘛，
但是之后我俩就共同要考研究生，
结果报一个地方，
但是没考到一个地方，
包括当时异地嘛，
离得特别的远，
工作以后反正也没有在一块儿，
之后对方就变心了，
就很坚定的要跟我分开，
我就那耗大概两年吧，
因为当时确实没办法接受，
刚开始他他的家庭啊，
他家人，
包括他对我都挺好的嘛，
然后就那耗两年分开了，
分开以后我就很迫切的就想再找下一段关系，
因为我就有那种特别不安的那种感觉，
通过我同学就认识一个我同学的一个导师，
我们是之前很早以前就认识，
因为跟我这个同学关系是特别的好，
我就说一下对方的一个情况嘛，
他比我大七岁，
今年是39。
他的睡前收入也挺高的，
应该是八九十的样子，
但是呢，
她有一个女儿是今年八岁，
但是这个女儿之前，
其实在她四岁的时候，
我们就也跟他见，
带着玩儿，
这种现在的问题就是跟这个男生相处起来，
因为他就是那种只对事业特别的有热情，
对我的话，
他只是刚开始可能会有一些时间呀，
或者是小礼物的一个东西，
现在相处了应该有一年多了，
我就感觉他在好多现实的问题，
就比方说刚开始他可能会主动买东西，
之后我也会主动给他，
他的家人买很多东西啊，
照顾他的生活，
但是现在的状态，
我感觉我一直在索取，
而且我的可能有一点不太对，
我老想用钱来证明他对我是上心的嘛，
所以我会要一些东西，
比方说生日的时候啊，
给我买个项链啊，
买个镯子这种的，
我俩也是有聊聊婚了，
但是结婚的时候我就感觉我俩聊什么彩彩笔啊，
包括说以后晚钱这种，
我可能不太想跟他妈妈住一起，
因为现在她的状况是他跟他妈妈在一块儿住，
还有他的孩子嘛，
他好像也不太认同，
以后我跟他跟他闺女在一块儿住，
他觉得不行，
包括钱上他就好像有点防备我，
因为之前可能就老找他要，
但是其实我内心并不是说贪图他的工资或啥，
我是觉得他人比较可靠，
但是我觉得他的思想好像就跟我都不是一样的，
就像他的成长，
他可能。
也是从苦日子涨上来的，
小时候就各种被看不起，
就比方说现在我给他买东西，
可能我多说一句，
说你看我对你好不好，
就这种话，
就是一个我觉得很俏皮或者很正常的一个话，
他就会觉得很有压力，
他就觉得我是在为以后张嘴要东西好张口，
而且他本人就是特别节俭，
他不光对我，
他对他的闺女家人也是这样。
我们最近一次吵架，
因为就聊到以后钱放一块儿，
他不愿意，
不愿意，
其实我能理解，
我们之前也聊过这个问题，
他之前告诉我说他可以分，
以后跟妈妈分开住，
只是我跟孩子一块儿，
但是他最近一次跟我提分手，
就是说他没有他妈妈，
他干不成事儿，
他觉得我可能不够理解，
他要跟我分开这个事情，
我感觉我内心可能还是比较脆弱的那种人，
我就很崩溃，
我都不太能接受现在的情况是，
所以就想着听一下您的建议，
看看跟这个人到底说考虑现实的情况应不应该在一块儿，
人家都要跟咱分手了，
咱现在考虑应不应该在一块儿，
这逻辑是不是不对呀？
这你有这个把握，
你能挽回吗？
挽回了之后你再有选择权吗？
他可能觉得跟谁在一块儿都行吧，
就就是这样吧，
我感觉不对，
姑娘啊，
你选择这个人的时候，
你没有认真去研究一下这个人的心理需求，
你的很多做法正好踩中了这个人的雷点，
因为某种程度上来说的话。
我个人是比较了解这类人的心理需求的，
吃苦嘛，
以前被人瞧不起嘛，
后来通过自己的努力，
有了一点钱，
有了一点成绩嘛，
对于这些人来说的话，
真的是钱就是命，
你三番五次的要我以给你买东西为一个证据来证明我喜欢你，
在我这里确实很下头的，
那我就在考虑我的弹出底了，
我就在考虑值不值得了。
如果我跟你在一起，
在情绪上又没有得到很多的反馈，
在事业上你又帮不上我，
人脉上资源上你也跟我没有任何的助力，
那光凭你漂亮，
光凭你年轻，
在我这里可能很难持续下去。
如果说人家已经提了要分手了，
那我们现在要考虑的问题是你有没有这个本事去挽回这段关系。
我在想这个人值不值得我在一块儿试一试，
或者是怎么样的，
这种你考虑这个东西呢，
也是情理之中的，
你说值得还是不值得，
她年入80万是吧，
但是呢，
他明确的说了，
她要跟她妈妈住在一起，
而且她有一个闺女，
八岁了，
其实这日子也没有想象中那么好过，
因为你自己也是年入20万的女性，
你自己也是非常优秀的，
你要找一个没有孩子的跟老公单独过的话，
我觉得你找一个跟你收入差不多的，
也是十几二十万的，
你俩这日子反而比找她更好过，
因。
你找他的话，
你得跟他妈妈生活在一起，
在他的世界里面的话，
你永远不可能排在很重要的位置，
要么就是他女儿排第一，
妈妈排第二，
要么就是妈妈排第一，
女儿排第二，
你永远都排不到前三里去，
因为还得观察自己呢，
看上去好像他一年挣80万，
你每次都在索取，
他从来没有想过要给你点啥，
要为你做点啥是不是？
嗯，
可能我经历了上一次的那个，
对我来说是个很大的一个打击，
感觉生活起来没有太多的知点，
有时候会觉得很虚无，
我老想着是不是以后我结婚了，
生了孩子居然有正经事儿做，
因为本身我工作也比较清闲的那种嘛，
我不知道会不会改善这种我心态上的一个问题，
或者说是因为我谈的起，
可能给不了我很稳定的一种感觉，
所以我就一直很纠结这个事情。
其实我们所有的女孩子啊，
这一生难免被辜负，
难免被抛弃，
难免会被别人筛选，
所有人都一样，
不管她长得再漂亮，
哪怕她是个女明星，
她这一生也会被人放弃，
也会被人说移情别恋，
都一样。
我感觉所有的人都得经历，
她再优秀，
她再漂亮，
她再有魅力，
她都会经历这个过程。
没有谁一辈子说常胜将军，
说谁跟她在一起的时候都没有离开过她，
即便是没有爱人离开过她，
有没有闺蜜离开过你，
有没有你的同学，
原来觉得挺好的，
后来人家不搭理你了，
都有。
很正常，
所以我觉得我谈了一个男朋友，
他最后他不喜欢我了，
他跟别人好了，
这是人生常态，
因为换你你也一样，
你从小长大的过程当中，
你肯定也辜负过别人的，
比如说你们班有同学对你特好，
呃，
特想跟你天天玩，
你不想跟他玩儿，
你就时间长了，
你就把他给慢慢的就淡出了你的人生了，
淡出了你的世界了，
这都太正常了。
如果说我因为有一个人，
他选择主动的离开我的世界，
我的世界就崩塌了，
那只能证明什么吗？
只能证明我的世界从来不曾真正的建过，
我的世界要建立起来，
一定是以我为中心的，
这话讲的太有哲理了，
我再说一遍啊，
我怎么那么牛，
如果一个人的离开可以导致我的世界崩塌的话，
只能证明我的世界从来未曾真正的建立过，
我的世界一定是以我为中心去建立起来的，
好的，
可能我工作感觉太可能给不了我太多的那种价值感，
嗯，
如果说哎，
你挣钱也挺多的啊，
你觉得你这个工作又挺清闲的啊，
养个宠物，
承担一点爱别人的责任，
我还有一个方向给你记录自己，
每天去记录自己到底我今天干了点啥，
干这个事情的话，
对别人有没有什么意义，
有没有什么价值啊，
我今天听到了什么观点，
我觉得这个观点对我的话，
人生豁然开朗啊，
我今天又看了一部什么电影，
这个电影里面那个角色，
我为什么喜欢他啊，
我今天又看了一个什么故事，
这个故事里面啊，
我能够从中又。
汲取到点什么经验教训，
下一次我再跟一个异性相处的时候，
我要改掉我自己曾经的一些什么样的毛病，
我分析我自己不很有意思的，
分析自己是一个特别有意思的事情，
分析别人研究人，
我跟你说龙菲姐为啥喜欢这个工作好不好，
我就喜欢研究人，
而且研究人特别有意思，
就像你就算跟这个男的分手了，
你是不是可以研究一下他，
像他这一类的人，
他真正的需求是什么，
他内心的渴望是什么，
他的恐惧是什么，
是不是挺有意思，
好的，
谢谢，
嗯，
谢谢你好，
这样啊，
拜拜，
我感觉我有的时候干这个工作，
他的意思就在于会迸发出我很多自己潜意识里的一些想法，
平时跟对象聊天，
跟晚辈们聊天，
跟同事们聊天，
可能迸发不出来这些潜意识里面觉得很有用的东西，
但是就是跟姐妹们聊天的过程当中会迸发出来，
某种程度上的话，
也是你们跟我连麦抛出这些问题去帮助我思考和成长，
我感觉这个过程真的很幸福啊，
记得点赞关注哦。